the search for the next Bachelor is over
and professor nation well it's a blast
from the shows reality past the sinking
in of your Nestle's a bachelor just sunk
in the news came as a shock to bachelor
nation
Rachel's ex Peter Krause had been in
discussions to be the next Bachelor but
according to ABC senior vice president
of programming Robert Mills he's still
emotionally raw after the breakup and
it's all about timing
he told ET in a phone interview today
quote it was just both sides saying it's
not 100% right Peter spoke out for the
first time today via Instagram saying
quote something held me back he went on
to say when you let uncertainty or fear
guide your decisions you risk missing
out on what could potentially be the
greatest opportunity of a lifetime
meanwhile unhappy fans have been working
their discontent on social media calling
out the almost 36 year old bachelor pic
as old and boring so exactly who is our
elion tech jr. well fans might remember
the racecar driver as Emily Maynard
runner up from season 8 of The
Bachelorette Emily and I just have a
great connection she's such a
down-to-earth beautiful girl
[Music]
because it's that good dubbed the
kissing bandit by bachelor fans he even
dated former bachelor bad girl Courtney
Robertson who described him as quote an
expert at lip locking and the best sex
she's ever had
re was originally set to be the bachelor
three years ago before being replaced by
Chris soules at the last minute a source
tells et that incident left re
embarrassed it's why he kept the news
top secret till this morning he didn't
even tell his parents
well he's finding out right now so